[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
when I see you now Jasha got it folks so
thank someone I once knew hiding in
plain sight I can never make out where
you start or ends your limbs are never
alone twisting bending grasping tight I
tried to trace the outline of a face a
black canvas so easily replaced as you
swell into a form I do not know I allow
myself this down with your shadow when I
see you now you shouted it was boxer dog
Bobby you of what you said you were with
every glimpse I see a new naked growth a
mess of thighs and calves laughter and
love a mess of emotions I've got
I tried to trace the outline of smile
but I heave a sickness spreadsheet and
my
and lets you swell I wave my hand toward
forest I say goodbye to the club and as
the fog engulfs limbs that I'll never
know I'm thankful that you let me go as
I took my chances on a clear I hope to
be set free from the carcass that had
once to release it you trapped me
but if only I could help you see that
these limbs
I'll cage every and blind finger every
breath against your skin every soft
progress only resolves to thicken the
folk that engulfs you the fog that hides
the fog that's what
or perhaps maybe I'm the one who can't
see and the fog was attached all along
to me
[Music]
[Music]
I'm happy don't worry never this a long
time ago